días movidos en el congreso de eeuu y
esa atención se veía fuera del capitolio
los republicanos están muy divididos
mientras el presidente del antro y los
demócratas en una rara coincidencia
quieren enviar cheques por dos mil
dólares a los estadounidenses para
paliar los efectos de la pandemia una
mayoría de los republicanos no quiere
que sean más de los 600 dólares ya
aprobados por ambas cámaras
mcconnell ha bloqueado una nueva
votación y piensa que los republicanos
más importantes han terminado por
reconocer la victoria de joe biden en
las elecciones de noviembre por primera
vez en muchos años una docena de
senadores de ese partido entre los que
se encuentra el ex aspirante
presidencial del club de texas amenazan
con convertir en un show la que ha sido
siempre una votación protocolaria para
ratificar los resultados del colegio
electoral en favor del ganador
respaldando las acusaciones sin
fundamento de fraude del presidente down
from que sigue sin reconocer su derrota
los senadores anunciaron que en la
sesión conjunta del congreso del 6 de
enero
protestarán los votos electorales de
algunos estados una justa y creíble
auditoría realizada inmediatamente y
completada mucho antes del 20 de enero
mejoraría radicalmente la fe de los
estados
unidenses en nuestro proceso electoral y
entretanto este domingo 3 de enero
cuando se posiciona el nuevo congreso
nancy pelosi lucha por ser elegida
presidenta de la cámara aunque en esta
ocasión tiene un margen más apretado
pues los demócratas aunque conservan una
mayoría de 222 frente a 211 de los
republicanos en ese organismo perdieron
10 escaños el 3 de noviembre por lo
visto la política en eeuu arranca 2021
tan polarizada como en 2020 y no sólo en
el congreso sino fuera de él este fin de
semana las casas de mis mcconnell
kentucky y nancy pelosi en san francisco
fueron vandalizadas